Ciao, sono la tua coscienza
Ciao sono la tua coscienza, che giorno è oggi?
No, non è il 32 di agosto cretina.
Oggi è il primo settembre, l'estate è ufficialmente finita.
Purtroppo ebbene sì
Oh mio Dio l'estate è finita ragazze
Oggi è il primo settembre e del journal johnes...
Dicevo, oggi è il primo settembre: la giornata ufficiale degli inizi dei buoni propositi, degli inizi della fine
Iniziamo subito con una breve lista dei buoni propositi!
Più più più più più
E sono tre
Fatti così sembrano sei...
Sono tre
Al numero uno il buono proposito
Al numero uno c'è sicuramente
La dieta quindi dimagrire e mangiare sano andare a fare sport almeno 2 volte a settimana iscriversi in palestra wow
Perché noi ci crediamo. Noi ci focalizziamo mettiamo post it in tutta la casa "è dieta"
Da oggi è dieta me lo sono ripromessa oggi è il primo settembre
Però è venerdì si potrebbe iniziare lunedì, ma no comunque preferisco di già
E poi dopo due secondi cadiamo nel baratro, della pizza, perché la pizza è la pizza
Alla numero 2 c'è ovviamente
L'università o la scuola, quindi per chi di voi va ancora a scuola
C'è ovviamente la voglia magari di arrivare a fine anno senza debiti quest'anno, che dite?
Che dite?! Ce la possiamo fare è certo questo è il proposito
Proprio più bello di tutti, ma per chi va all'università invece c'è
La gioia di passare almeno un esame, di riuscire a laurearsi in tempo
Ecco vi sono vicina... ci sono passata  anch'io
Era bellissimo all'università quando arrivava la sessione estiva dare qualche esame magari a giugno e poi quelli di luglio insomma ecco ma li darò a settembre ...
Mai dati
Eeeeeeeee
Troppi ricordi, non ce la faccio
E alla numero 3 come sempre arriva l'amore e speriamo che Dio ce lo mandi sano di mente stavolta
Vabbè poi oltre a sano di mente anche
Carino, fisicato, intelligente, che non mi tradisca, che sia simpatico alle mie amiche eee che piaccia ai miei genitori ovviamente, se no eh non se parte...
Il 90% degli italiani soffre di sindrome da buoni propositi
Nessuno di loro porta a compimento questi buoni propositi.
È una piaga forte, una piaga che va combattuta. Chiamate subito il numero verde 800 800 94 66
Sosteniamo anche noi una persona che non porterà avanti i buoni propositi del primo settembre
Se vi è piaciuto il video ragazzi ricordatevi di lasciare un piccolo commento di mettere like se non siete ancora iscritti al mio canale iscrivetevi assolutamente
E seguitemi sugli altri social instagram, musically e facebook
Un bacione. Adoro!